so Joe McGrane let me start with you
first David Blevins they're talking
about the language of alignment and in
particular regulatory alignment which is
apparently satisfactory to britain and
regulatory divergence which wasn't can
you explain the difference in in the
real world no abundant politics that
could be five miles apart I mean I think
the important thing is to acknowledge
that people are working really hard on
all science today as we can see and to
bring about a form of words that does
work and all that Don today has hit the
pause button of the stubborn allure
effectively two weeks to find the formal
words and it's clear that the UK
including Northern Ireland is working
hard along with the areas governed and
the EU to find a form of words that does
meet the eu27 s needs for assurances of
Northern Ireland so you're fairly
confident then John that's some kind of
recraft enough the text is possible to
honor to satisfy on all sides confident
in politics anything is possible and
where people want to make something
happen in politics they usually do and
it's clear that a lot of work has gone
in to bring people this close and with
two weeks my own sense is that the good
will has been evidenced under and the if
you like the agreement on common purpose
has been focused enough by the deadline
to get us to this day so two weeks I
think is as people have been saying in
in recent days a doable amount of time
in which to get a deal done and UK
including Northern Ireland does know
that we really do need to use that time
well to get a deal because all borders
are bad and all borders are bad for
business and any boredom anywhere
frankly between all right Edwin let me
bring you in at this point
I mean how on earth do you bridge the
divide between what Dublin wants and
what the DUP apparently wants well it's
been quite strange watching this all
play out from from London I suppose
because we've had all the different
players slightly different views on
things these tiny disagreements about by
the language at least they are talking
about the language if you've got a text
on the table you're a lot closer to if
I'm an agreement then perhaps we thought
it was going to be a few weeks ago I
mean really what matters is whether or
not they can get a deal at this summit
and
that's the the only thing really
businesses care about and what about the
point that David Blevins was making Jess
now if a special deal is done for
Northern Ireland Scotland and London
other remaining voting areas will want
similar treatment when they I it starts
getting very messy when you're trying to
end the UK breaks up like that
I clearly doesn't seem like the dup want
that to happen I think from from a
business point of view actually a deal
that works for the whole of the UK
probably is the right thing it's really
just about finding then that space the
the Republic of Ireland's Northern
Ireland and frankly the Westminster
government can all sort of come together
and we really hope we hit that in a
couple weeks all right well John um
we've referred tonight it's in fact is
being suggested right now this term
regulatory alignment is being offered
for the whole of the UK by trees in May
but only in limited areas of the Good
Friday Agreement such as agriculture and
energy policy and so forth do you think
that's going to be enough for both sides
no the reality is that you know we
talked about north-south borders
east-west borders borders in the sea we
certainly don't want to compound that by
also adding borders between sectors
sectors that are in sectors that are out
because we all know how that can be
gained how it can spawn other sorts of
activity and it's not really the way
forward what we want is a common
agreement of the fact that border
lessness coupled with if you like
similarity and standards because nobody
in the UK is saying that the UK wants to
default to lowered standards of public
health of safety of food or anything
like that so this is about commonality
of standards across the province and
across the UK and with with Ireland and
the rest of the eu27 and youth and John
Irish businesses at the moment dthe what
are you hearing from members right now
other than the fact that
crikey let's just go on and do a deal
quickly I think there's a genuine
appreciation in Irish business as there
is in UK business and EU business that
politics is a tough business of people
have to work hard to bring together
really you know complex different points
of view so business is behind our public
representatives on this understands that
the hard work has to be done doesn't
want any further delays because the
clock is ticking
preparing for replacement rules and
replacement regulations but time is
running on and we do need to use the
next two weeks very well so the frankly
we don't miss the December deadline in
which case it becomes too late for many
businesses to prepare Edwin you have you
been fielding calls this afternoon from
anxious members hum and you that you
confident that we will get something by
the December deadline confident I have
no idea where they say a conference I
think maybe we are probably more
confident than we were a few weeks ago
right
but it's it's it's so important the
reason we need to get this movement now
is because we need to move on to
transition because that buys us some
more time if we can get a transitional
agreement a couple years after March
2019 that buys businesses sometimes they
don't have to do the big continuously
planning right now don't spend the big
moves and that really helps everything
one final thought Edwin I guess a DEP
have to be careful they don't overplay
their hand because they could end up
with a famous ally of Xin Thayne in
number 10 Downing Street I'm not sure I
want to get too deeply into Northern
Irish politics I think the one thing on
that is that we have lots of members in
Northern Ireland and certainly for a
long time they were you know kind of
ignored as part of this question but now
they're back in it okay
Edwin Morgan here in London drama grain
in Dublin thanks both for joining me